في حفل زفاف اسطوري في بالم بيتش بولايه
فلوريدا الامريكيه احتفل الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب على مدار عده ايام لزفاف
ابنته تفني على الملياردير اللبناني مايكل
بولوس العرب تركوا بصمه كبيره على هذا
الحفل ليس بالعريس فقط فالعروس ارتدت
مجوهرات من تصميم اللبنانيه سامر حليمه
الذي يعد من ابرز تجار المجوهرات في
نيويورك كما تالق تيفاني خلال الحفل بثوب
زفاف حمل توقيع المصمم اللبناني اليسا ولم
تكن الاطلال الوحيده التي حملت توقيع دار
صعب في الحفل بل كان الثوب الابيض الضيق
والطويل الذي ارتدته العروس خلال العشاء
الذي تلى حفل الزفاف ايضا
البدله السوداء التي ارتداها العريس في
الحفل والده العروس بدورها اختاري الثوبا
يحمل توقيع المصمم ايلي صعب باللون
اللافندر وهو ما فعلته وصيفه العروس
شقيقتها ايفانكا لكن باللون الازرق لذا
يمكننا القول ان حفله زفاف الاسطوري كان
لبنانيا وامريكا ولكن من هو صهر ترامب
الجديد الجواب مع لميسي ابراهيم
قد يكون دونالد ترامب من قبل بعض امتلاك
مشاعر سلبيه تجاه الاجانب لكن الحقيقه انه
بات لديه صهر جديد من العالم العربي
وبالتحديد من لبنان فمن هو مايكل بول
الساهر ترامب الجديد اريد مايكل في لبنان
عام
19970 لكنه نشا في نيجيريا ويقول مقربون
منه صباح العربيه انه كاميرا على يده
مربيه النيجيريات واحب الطعام النيجر
وتعلق بهذا البلد الافريقي الذي صنعها
ثروه عائلته درس في لندن لكن حس رجل
الاعمال ورثه عن والده مسعد بولوس وهو
المدير العام للمجموعه ضخمه من الشركات
لكن الملك الحقيقي لتلك الشركات ومؤسسها
هو جاءت مايكل لوالدته زهير فضول احد كبار
الاثرياء المنحدرين من بلده بيت شباب
الشهيره تاثر مايكل كثيرا في طفولته
امامت بعائلته حيث قتل عدد من اقاربه في
تحطم طائره كانت تقلهم من وفي افريقيا الى
لبنان وكان هدفهم حينها حضور العزاء لما
سع عائليه اخرى يختلف مايكل عن شقيقه عن
شقيقه هو شقيقته فهو يميل الى عالم
الاعمال وهم يميلون الى الفن مثل والدتهم
ساره بولس التي اسس جمعيه للفنون المسرحيه
في نيجيريا في عام 2018 التقط المصورون
اول لقطه فني ترامب مع مايكل
محظوظ كفايه يتقدم بعرض الزواج من امام
البيت والدها الذي كان حينها البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]